in the uk gas prices have spiked there
are warnings of an energy crunch coming
this winter and it is not just here
across europe energy prices are rising
fast and in the united states this year
there have been blackouts in texas and
difficulties with the power grid in
california as well so how do we go about
solving this energy crisis and still
stick to the climate agenda and mikhail
coming to you first we were showing our
data dashboard earlier looking at the
power mix that we use to generate our
electricity is still heavily reliant on
fossil fuels but particularly gas how do
we wean a country off its reliance on
gas
you're asking the
the most important question how do we
wean ourselves off fossil fuels and the
answer is we do it boldly and fiercely
and urgently we do it by starting to
invest immediately not only in um
first of all uh insulating homes uh
something that uh uh often ties poor
housing and uh and fuel poverty and uh
increases the impact on those who are
already suffering the most um
that would have resulted in a
significantly lower uh gas
bills for all of those
in the in the uk that now have to pay
the higher price secondly we need to
build infrastructure we need to invest
in research and development we need to
invest in deployment all of these things
are good things for the economy they
provide jobs they provide local jobs
they reduce dependence on uh on imports
they reduce dependence on fossil fuels
that need storage they reduce all of
those things that um we really need to
get uh off
and michael john kerry has said that 50
of the technologies that we need to do
this don't exist yet where should we be
putting our attentions is it storage is
it something else
yeah i took issue with him when he said
that um i think he misspoke what he
meant was in 2050 several decades down
the road when we do have new
technologies we can't even envision yet
they will be contributing to
decarbonization in the middle of the
century as we go towards xero but in the
meantime we have the technology
renewable energy technology to
decarbonize our economy now to reach 50
reduction in carbon emissions by the end
of the decade which is what we have to
do writ large and it's what the the
dividend administration has pledged to
do but as mccall said this is about
infrastructure it's about making sure
that we have smart grid technology so
that when the wind isn't blowing or the
sun isn't shining we have energy storage
pumped hydro battery technology all of
these things are going to come together
and they're going to be essential along
with as macaula again said
energy efficiency we can make quite a
bit of progress simply by being more
efficient with the energy that we do
produce
you